pas après les fusées les bateaux avec le
rendez-vous des yachts de luxe à monaco
et voici la nouvelle mode transformer
des remorqueurs des brise glaces des
chalutiers en bateau de croisière pour
particuliers correspondance nathalie
jourdan nathalie morin intime dans et
rassurant 75 m de long la banquise
il en fait des glaçons mais ce
brise-glace est apprivoisé il balade les
milliardaires en mal de mer et à plein
le choc est rude et vaart deyaert qui
sont allées entre lacoste baby chose que
nous vaut partir loin longtemps par tous
temps et sur tous les océans
mais avec la manière robuste dehors
grand luxe à bord chambre pour gardes du
corps en cas de mutinerie peut-être
reconvertir un brise glace ou un
remorqueur en yacht de luxe une récup
très tendance d'ailleurs certains
chantiers ne transforme pas il fabrique
de toutes pièces des yachts
d'exploration pour clients fortunés et
exigeants ils vont passer souvent
beaucoup plus de temps sur ces bateaux
là que les propriétaires qui sont sur
des bateaux beaucoup plus design et en
fait parce qu'ils nous veulent aller à
leur famille veulent voyager il faut
entreprendre un tour du monde
les clients de riches industriels
américains ou européens des familles du
golfe
des stars du showbiz tous jouent au
commandant cousteau
ça fait des années qu'on voit ses
efforts à la télé on connaît toutes ses
aventures
on veut tous faire pareil jouer aux
grands explorateurs coûte cher très cher
300 mille dollars la semaine sur ce
brise-glace sont le couvert ni le fuel
cher donc mais beaucoup moins tape à
l'oeil que la belle anglaise sur le pont